hi I on the button lady why do they call
you that just came at me one day um my
questions were Sophie hi Sophie hi
you've had a really great year with his
character and I was just wondering when
you're reading the scripts at home or
wherever you first read them what scene
really made you giggle to yourself but
hallo I can't wait that [ __ ] out of this
oh it was 100% around sorry I feel like
it's whoa the past five seasons have
been kind of building up to this and her
I'm getting really just try to be white
I feel like it's rebuilding us this and
you know her first kale and I'm so glad
it was Ramsay and it was written so well
and so much she quoted that to me the
other day and apart someone was like
your house will disappear your family
disappear and I thought it was from the
show I thought they were cursing I just
love the way it was written it was
wonderful and I was very excited to do
it with this little scrapper it was an
honor to be killed by you a girl would
like to know oh yeah what was the
favorite part of training
bring I write things and I guess they
were kind of choreographed like dances
um and so we spent like a month in
Northern Ireland doing that and I
remember one day where amazing they were
really really not actually this was
after filming so after we filmed episode
5 I we we spent all day to night it was
so much fun but me mazie were hitting
each other a lot
identity day was so tired I went back to
my hotel room and fell asleep face down
in a plate of salmon so that's a good
day you know I woke up it's like this
look in a mirror was like man that was
to fish so yeah probably probably not
gangs we were both retired but we had
like a lot of fun yeah salmon face also
should we said that hi hi Natalie and
the rest of the cast I owe this question
is actually for Sophie oh oh yeah oh
jeez
basically so Jon Snow and salsa aren't
really brother and sister and Dan asked
me they likes red ants Oh mother so I
was wondering
she likes red II don't
he likes so I don't know what you well I
was wondering like what kind of issues
you think a good cause for funds skin
the party started um um John likes
redheads he does but ostrich won't burn
up together they may as well be siblings
they have that sibling rivalry I don't
know but I swear to god David that if
you make anything occur to us but thank
you nothing will happen
engine Coldhands is back yeah but I
guess the panel if there are any great
stories
honey that I'd like to share during the
production this season
KITT farted a lot exclusive
where's the vodka hi there my name is
Nicole and I just wanted to ask grant a
question I just wanted to ask you how
you felt when you found out about when
you had the vision of Jon Snow being
born like well I mean is that was it
like an eye-opener for you and it made
everything make sense
or was it just something that need you
more confused well because the Tower of
joy stuff was split into kind of two
scenes one earlier in the season the
more later in the season so when I first
read it my immediate thought was I'm
going to Spain I'm going somewhere warm
rather than yes and I actually read it
and I suppose overall it's a very
interesting kind of arc the whole
everything that happens within the Tower
of joy and I wasn't actually aware of
the whole I knew I knew about our
personal equals jail and so forth but
the Tower of joy I hadn't actually plan
across I'd read up on it and fallible
theories and so it was it was it was
really cool to just be able to read it
let alone actually it had involvement in
the scene I think that was what was so
cool about brans visions was that it
wasn't just the audience watching a
flashback or something happened it was
the audience getting to watch and other
character reacts to this kind of rich
history of Westeros and so for me
personally yeah it kind of it was nice
to see it all click together um my
question is for Sofie um since the
beginning of the series Sansa has made
like a complete
transformation she's almost like a new
character how do you think that
transformation is going to continue and
where do you think she's going to end up
wow that's a really good question
because I genuinely have no idea I feel
like I could take her in so many
directions
um I mean she's really become kind of a
leader in her own right but there's also
that sense after she had that scene
where she killed Ramsey you wonder if
she's kind of got a taste for killing I
mean Michelle up to Michelle
vodka Michelle and I just felt that
scene offensively and we really wanted
to kind of accentuate to kind of
accentuate that um what'd he say
remembering um we really wanted to kind
of accentuate that that kind of look
back where she she almost walks away and
she looks back in civic to the to the
kennels with this kind of passion for it
and this real injury and I don't know
you yeah we was like that was hot there
was a we spent a long time messing
around with that scene but whereas she's
using it because it seemed it was
there's such a wish fulfillment aspect
to it
it's that's the thing that everybody has
been waiting to see for quite some time
and that she's been waiting for and we
needed to milk it but not too much and
we also needed to remain slightly
ambiguous about what her feelings were
about it but I think one of the things
that clinched is when so there's a
close-up of Sophie and she goes to leave
and then she kind of pauses and then she
gets drawn back into it just as you're
hearing you and scream like a pig yeah
um so yes an answer to your question I
honestly have no idea if she's gonna
become a real leader and and do the
right thing be a true star cause she's
gonna go cutely sadistic oh no we'll
soon find out watch season seven okay
great hi hi my name is Tyrion and I
question for all of the females up there
how does it feel to be such strong women
in the show and does it kind of affect
your lives outside of it man how does it
feel personally me um
it's awesome yeah it's really short
answer it's really it's empowered and
it's awesome and especially the way if
she gets to do so much cool sort of
fight it's wicked you know it's really
cool so feel very lucky to have played a
badass
definitely yeah yeah I feel really proud
to be playing such a strong woman in the
show I think the Sandi's has such an
interesting where she began and like
just her evolution as a human being has
been really fun to play and like her
intelligence and have her business even
though it's quite quiet she's had quite
a lot to overcome and she's really
persevered and I've definitely enjoyed
people's response to her because people
have come up to me before and said
really wonderful things about it and I I
like I feel really pleased that people
respond to her and feel connected to her
and her quiet that kind of strong she's
strong in a very quiet way so people
I'm happy that I hey guys um I would
really big fan by the way thank you I
just want to ask how your character
slash experience with the show has
impacted your life life-changing I would
say for me yeah I never I'd never been
to California until two years ago and
I'd never been paid as much in my life
I've had such a good time but on such an
excellent piece of work
it sort of spoils you for everything
else because nothing else lives up to
the production values and just every
because we've been working for so long
together every department works together
so brilliantly and it's just been an
amazing experience and I wouldn't swap
it for the world
if we had time for one more question
ah wait let's make it to this is your hi
my name's sky and my question is for
Christian seeing as he died so heroic
leaf or brand I was wondering if there's
anything he would say to bran if he
could express anything more than owed or
Fox how's your own um yeah
yeah I've been asked a question before
about what would hear that the first
word you would say to the brown and ever
hits up they speak and ever definitely
didn't know hey who torchic me Tyra me
to that tree I think hooter would be
happy the way he died I think he would
be I think he enjoyed attacking and
looking after and as I did with Isaac
here for the last six years I got a
lesson
so I'll never get read with them really
good
I never you're better be really nice
you